spirituality
is a particular term
which actually
means
dealing with
intuition
in the theistic tradition
there is notion of
clinging into a word
a certain act is regarded as
displeasing
to divine principles
certain act is regarded as pleasing
for the divine
whatever
in the tradition of non-theism however
it is very direct
that the kids history are not
particularly important
what is actually important is here and
now here and now
now it's definitely now
we try to experience what is available
there on the spot
there is no point in
thinking that the past did exist that we
could have now
is now
this very moment this very moment
nothing mystical just now very simple
straightforward
and from that now this however
arises
a sense of intelligence
always
that you are constantly interacting with
reality
one by one spot by spot
constantly
we actually experience a fantastic
precision always
but we are threatened by the now
so we jump to the past or the future
paying attention to
the materials that exist in our life
all these choices takes place all the
time
but none of them are regarded as a bad
or good per se
everything we experience our
unconditional experience
they don't come along with the label by
saying this regard is bad
this is good
but we experienced them but we don't
actually pay heed to them
properly
we don't actually regard that as that we
are going somewhere
regard that as a hassle
waiting to be dead
waiting to be dead
waiting to be dead
the problem
and that is not trusting the narrowness
properly that what is actually
experienced now
possessed a lot of
powerful things
it is so powerful
that we can't face it
therefore we have to borrow from the
past
invite future
all the time
and maybe that's why we seek religion
religion maybe that's why we
march in the street
maybe that's why we complain to the
society
maybe that's why
we vote for the presidents
it's quite ironical
very funny indeed
[Applause]
the more you begin to investigate
what we think we understand
where we came from what we think we're
doing
the more you begin to see we've been
lied to
we've been lied to by every institution
what makes you think for one minute that
the religious institution is the only
one that's never been touched
the religious institutions of this world
are at the bottom
of the dirt
the religious institutions in this world
are put there by the same people who
gave you your government your corrupt
education to set up your international
banking cartels
we have been misled away from the true
and divine presence in the universe that
men have called god
i don't know what god is but i know what
he isn't
and unless and until you are prepared
to look at the whole truth and wherever
it may go whoever it may lead to
the more you educate yourself the more
you understand where things come from
the more obvious things become and you
begin to see lies everywhere you have to
know the truth and seek the truth and
the truth will set you free
[Music]
[Music]
because i got to tell you the truth
folks i gotta tell you the truth
when it comes to [ __ ]
big time
major league [ __ ] you have to stand
in awe
of the all-time champion of false
promises and exaggerated claims
religion
think about it religion has actually
convinced people
that there's an invisible man
living in the sky
who watches everything you do every
minute of every day and the invisible
man has a special list of 10 things he
does not want you to do
and if you do any of these ten things he
has a special place full of fire and
smoke and burning and torture and
anguish where he will send you to live
and suffer and burn and choke and scream
and cry forever and ever till the end of
time
but he loves you
[Applause]
he loves you and he needs money
he always needs money
he's all powerful all perfect
all-knowing and all wise somehow
just can't handle money
religion takes in billions of dollars
they pay no taxes and they always need a
little more
now you talk about a good [ __ ] story
holy [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the sun
as far back as 10 000 bc history is
abundant with carvings and writings
reflecting people's respect and
adoration for this object
and it is simple to understand why as
every morning that someone rides
bringing vision warmth and security
saving man from the cold blind
predator-filled darkness of night
without it the cultures understood the
crops would not grow and life on the
planet would not survive
these realities made the sun the most
adored object of all time
likewise they were also very aware of
the stars
the tracking of the stars allowed them
to recognize and anticipate events which
occurred over long periods of time
such as eclipses and full moons
they in turn catalog celestial groups
into what we know today as
constellations
this is the cross of the zodiac one of
the oldest conceptual images in human
history
it reflects the sun as it figuratively
passes through the 12 major
constellations over the course of a year
it also reflects the 12 months of the
year the four seasons and the solstices
and equinoxes
the term zodiac relates to the fact that
constellations were anthropomorphized
or personified as figures or animals
in other words the early civilizations
did not just follow the sun and stars
they personified them with elaborate
myths involving their movements and
relationships
the sun with its life-giving and saving
qualities was personified as a
representative of the unseen creator or
god
god's son the light of the world the
savior of humankind
likewise the 12 constellations
represented places of travel for god's
son and were identified by names usually
representing elements of nature that
happened during that period of time
for example aquarius the water bearer
who brings the spring rains
[Music]
this is horus
he is the sun god of egypt of around
3000 bc
he is the sun anthropomorphized and his
life is a series of allegorical myths
involving the sun's movement in the sky
from the ancient hieroglyphics in egypt
we know much about the solar messiah
for instance horus being the sun or the
light had an enemy known as set and set
was the personification of the darkness
or night
and metaphorically speaking every
morning horus would win the battle
against set
while in the evening set would conquer
horus and send him into the underworld
it is important to note that dark versus
light or good versus evil is one of the
most ubiquitous mythological dualities
ever known
and is still expressed on many levels to
this day
[Music]
broadly speaking the story of horus is
as follows
horus was born on december 25th of the
virgin isis mary
his birth was accompanied by a star in
the east and upon his birth he was
adored by three kings
at the age of 12 he was a prodigal child
teacher at the age of 30 he was baptized
by a figure known as anap and thus began
his ministry horus had 12 disciples he
traveled about with performing miracles
such as healing the sick and walking on
water
horus was known by many gestural names
such as the truth the light god's
anointed son the good shepherd the lamb
of god and many others
after being betrayed by typhon horus was
crucified buried for three days and thus
resurrected
these attributes of horus whether
original or not seem to permeate many
cultures of the world from many other
gods are found to have the same general
mythological structure
addis a phrygia born in the virgin
non-on december 25th crucified placed in
a tomb and after three days was
resurrected
krishna of india born of the virgin
devaki with a star in the east signaling
his coming he performed miracles with
his disciples and upon his death was
resurrected
dionyses of greece born of a virgin on
december 25th was a traveling teacher
who performed miracles such as turning
water into wine he was referred to as
the king of kings god's only begotten
son the alpha and omega and many others
and upon his death he was resurrected
mithra of persia born of a virgin on
december 25th he had 12 disciples and
performed miracles and upon his death
was buried for three days and thus
resurrected he was also referred to as
the truth the light and many others
interestingly the sacred day of worship
of mithra was sunday
the fact of the matter is there are
numerous saviors from different periods
from all over the world which subscribe
to these general characteristics
the question remains why these
attributes
why the virgin birth on december 25th
why dead for three days the inevitable
resurrection why 12 disciples are
followers
to find out let's examine the most
recent of the solar messiahs
[Music]
jesus christ was born of the virgin mary
on december 25th in bethlehem his birth
was announced by a star in the east
which three kings or magi followed to
locate and adorn the new savior he was a
child teacher at 12 at the age of 30 he
was baptized by john the baptist and
thus began his ministry
jesus had 12 disciples which he traveled
about with performing miracles such as
healing the sick walking on water
raising the dead he was also known as
the king of kings the son of god the
light of the world the alpha omega the
lamb of god and many many others after
being betrayed by his disciple judas and
sold for 30 pieces of silver he was
crucified placed in a tomb and after
three days was resurrected and sended
into heaven
first of all the birth sequence is
completely astrological
the star in the east is serious the
brightest star in the night sky which on
december 24th aligns with the three
brightest stars in orion's belt these
three bright stars and orion's belt are
called today what they were called in
ancient times the three kings
and the three kings and the brightest
star sirius all point to the place of
the sunrise on december 25th
this is why the three kings follow the
star in the east in order to locate the
sunrise
the birth of the sun
[Music]
the virgin mary is the constellation
virgo also known as virgo the virgin
virgo in latin means virgin
burger was also referred to as the house
of bread and the representation of virgo
is a virgin holding a sheaf of wheat
this house of bread and its symbol of
wheat represents august and september
the time of harvest in turn bethlehem in
fact literally translates to house of
bread bethlehem is thus a reference to
the constellation virgo a place in the
sky not on earth
there's another very interesting
phenomenon that occurs around december
25th or the winter solstice from the
summer solstice to the winter solstice
the days become shorter and colder and
from the perspective of the northern
hemisphere the sun appears to move south
and gets smaller and more scarce the
shortening of the days and the
expiration of the crops when approaching
the winter solstice symbolized the
process of death to the ancients
it was the death of the sun
and by december 22nd the sun's demise
was fully realized for the sun having
moved south continually for six months
makes it to its lowest point in the sky
here a curious thing occurs
the sun stops moving south
at least perceivably for three days and
during this three-day pause the sun
resides in the vicinity of the southern
cross or crux constellation
and after this time on december 25th the
sun moves one degree this time north
foreshadowing longer days warmth and
spring
and thus it was said
the sun
died on the cross was dead for three
days
only to be resurrected or born again
this is why jesus and numerous other sun
gods share the crucifixion three-day
death and resurrection concept
it is the sun's transition period before
it shifts its direction back into the
northern hemisphere bringing spring and
thus salvation
however they did not celebrate the
resurrection of the sun until the spring
equinox or easter
this is because at the spring equinox
the sun officially overpowers the evil
darkness as daytime thereafter becomes
longer in duration than the night and
the revitalizing conditions of spring
emerge
now probably the most obvious of all the
astrological symbolism around jesus
regards the 12 disciples
they are simply the 12 constellations of
the zodiac which jesus being the son
travels about with
in fact the number 12 is replete
throughout the bible
coming back to the cross of the zodiac
the figurative life of the sun
this was not just an artistic expression
or tool to track the sun's movement
it was also a pagan spiritual symbol
the shorthand of which looked like this
this is not a symbol of christianity it
is a pagan adaptation of the cross of
the zodiac
[Music]
this is why jesus and early occult art
is always shown with his head on the
cross for jesus is the son
the son of god the light of the world
the risen savior who will come again as
it does every morning
the glory of god who defends against the
works of darkness
as he is born again every morning
and can be seen coming in the clouds
up in heaven
with his crown of thorns or
sun rays
now
of the many astrological astronomical
metaphors in the bible
one of the most important has to do with
the ages
throughout the scriptures there are
numerous references to the age
in order to understand this we need to
be familiar with a phenomenon known as
the procession of the equinoxes
the ancient egyptians along with
cultures long before them recognized
that approximately every 2150 years the
sun rise on the morning of the spring
equinox would occur in a different sign
of the zodiac
this has to do with a slow angular
wobble that the earth maintains as it
rotates on its axis
[Music]
it is called a procession because the
constellations go backwards rather than
through the normal yearly cycle
the amount of time it takes for the
procession to go through all 12 signs is
roughly 25
765 years
this is also called the great year
and ancient societies were very aware of
this and they referred to each 2150 year
period as an age
from 4300 bc to 2150 bc it was the age
of taurus the bull from 2150 bc to 180
it was the age of aries the ram and from
1ad to 2150 a.d it is the age of pisces
the age we are still in to this day
and in and around 2150 we will enter the
new age the age of aquarius
now the bible reflects broadly speaking
a symbolic movement through three ages
while foreshadowing a fourth
in the old testament when moses comes
down mount sinai with the ten
commandments he is very upset to see his
people worshiping a golden bull calf
in fact he shattered the stone tablets
and instructed his people to kill each
other in order to purify themselves most
biblical scholars will attribute this
anger to the fact that the israelites
were worshiping a false idol or
something to that effect
the reality is the golden bull is taurus
the bull and moses represents the new
age of ares the rand
this is why jews even today still blow
the rams horn
moses represents the new age of aries
and upon the new age everyone must shed
the old age
other deities mark these transitions as
well such as mithra a pre-christian god
who kills the bull in the same symbology
now jesus is the figure who ushers in
the age following ares the age of pisces
or the two fish
fish symbolism is very abundant in the
new testament jesus feeds five thousand
people with bread and two fish
when he begins his ministry walking
along galilee he befriends to fishermen
who follow him
and i think we have all seen the jesus
fish on the back of people's cars
little do they know what it actually
means
it is a pagan astrological symbolism for
the sun's kingdom during the age of
pisces
also jesus's assumed birth date is
essentially the start of this age
at luke 22 10 when jesus is asked by his
disciples where the last passover would
be
jesus replies
behold when ye are entered into the city
there shall a man meet you bearing a
pitcher of water follow him into the
house where he entereth in
this scripture is by far one of the most
revealing of all the astrological
references
the man bearing the picture of water is
aquarius the water bearer
who is always pictured as a man pouring
out a pitcher of water
he represents the age after pisces and
when the sun god's son leaves the age of
pisces jesus
it will go into the house of aquarius as
aquarius follows pisces in the
procession of the equinoxes
all jesus is saying is that after the
age of pisces will come the age of
aquarius
now we have all heard about the end
times in the end of the world
the cartoonish depictions in the book of
revelation aside the main source of this
idea comes from matthew 28 20 where
jesus says i will be with you even to
the end of the world however in the king
james version world is a mistranslation
among many mistranslations
the actual word being used is eon
which means age
i will be with you even to the end of
the age
which is true as jesus's solar piscean
personification will end when the sun
enters the age of aquarius the entire
concept of end times in the end of the
world is a misinterpreted astrological
allegory
let's tell that to the approximately 100
million people in america who believe
the end of the world is coming
furthermore the character of jesus being
a literary and astrological hybrid is
most explicitly a plagiarization of the
egyptian sun god horus
for example inscribed about 3 500 years
ago on the walls at the temple of luxor
in egypt are images of the annunciation
the miracle conception the birth and the
adoration of horus
the images begin with thoth announcing
to the virgin isis that she will
conceive horus
then neph the holy ghost impregnating
the virgin
and then the virgin birth and the
adoration
this is exactly the story of jesus's
miracle conception
in fact the literary similarities
between the egyptian religion and the
christian religion are staggering
and the plagiarism is continuous the
story of noah and noah's ark is taken
directly from tradition
the concept of the great flood is
ubiquitous throughout the ancient world
with over 200 cited claims in different
periods and times however one knee
looked no further for a pre-christian
source than the epic of gilgamesh
written in 2600 bc
this story talks of a great flood
commanded by god an ark with saved
animals upon it and even the release and
return of a dove
all held in common with the biblical
story among many other similarities
and then there is the plagiarized story
of moses upon moses birth it is said
that he was placed in a reed basket and
set adrift in a river in order to avoid
infanticide
he was later rescued by a daughter of
royalty and raised by her as a prince
this baby in a basket story was lifted
directly from the myth of sargon of
akkad of around 2250 bc
sargon was born placed in a reed basket
in order to avoid infanticide and set
adrift in a river
he was in turn rescued and raised by aki
a royal midwife
furthermore moses is known as the law
giver the giver of the ten commandments
the mosaic law however the idea of a law
being passed from god to a prophet up on
a mountain is also a very old motif
moses is just another lawgiver a long
line of lawgivers in mythological
history
in india manu was the great lawgiver in
crete minos ascended mount dicta where
zeus gave him the sacred laws while in
egypt there was mises who carried stone
tablets and upon them the laws of god
were written
manu
minos mises moses
and as far as the ten commandments they
are taken outright from spell 125 in the
egyptian book of the dead what the book
of the dead phrased i have not stolen
became thou shall not steal i have not
killed became thou shall not kill i have
not told lies became thou shall not bear
false witness and so forth
in fact the egyptian religion is likely
the primary foundational basis for the
judeo-christian theology baptism
afterlife final judgment virgin birth
death and resurrection crucifixion the
ark of the covenant circumcision saviors
holy communion great flood easter
christmas passover
and many many more are all attributes of
egyptian ideas long predating
christianity and judaism
justin martyr one of the first christian
historians and defenders
wrote when we say that he jesus christ
our teacher was produced without sexual
union was crucified and died and rose
again and ascended into heaven
we propound nothing different from what
you believe regarding those who you
esteem sons of jupiter
in a different writing justin martyr
said he was born of a virgin except this
in common with what you believe of
perseus
it's obvious that justin and other early
christians knew how similar christianity
was to the pagan religions
however justin had a solution
as far as he was concerned
the devil did it
the devil had the foresight to come
before christ and create his
characteristics in the pagan world
fundamentalist christianity fascinating
these people actually believe the world
is 12 000 years old
[Music]
i actually asked one of these guys okay
dinosaur apostles
he says
dinosaur fossils god put those here to
test our faith
i think god put you here to test my
faith dude
the bible is nothing more than astro
literary hybrid just like nearly all
religious myths before it
in fact the aspect of transference of
one character's attributes to a new
character can be found within the book
itself in the old testament there is the
story of joseph
joseph was a prototype for jesus
joseph was born of a miracle birth jesus
was born of a miracle birth
joseph was of 12 brothers jesus had 12
disciples
joseph was sold for 20 pieces of silver
jesus was sold for 30 pieces of silver
brother judah suggests the sale of
joseph disciple judas suggests the sale
of jesus
joseph began his work at the age of 30
jesus began his work at the age of 30.
the parallels go on and on
furthermore is there any non-biblical
historical evidence of any person living
with the name jesus the son of mary who
traveled about with 12 followers healing
people and the like there are numerous
historians who lived in and around the
mediterranean either during or soon
after the assumed life of jesus
how many of these historians document
this figure
not one
however to be fair that doesn't mean
defenders of the historical jesus
haven't claimed the contrary four
historians are typically referenced to
justify jesus's existence pliny the
younger satonius and tacitus are the
first three each one of their entries
consists of only a few sentences at best
and only referred to priestess or the
christ which in fact is not a name but a
title it means the anointed one
the fourth source is josephus and this
source has been proven to be a forgery
for hundreds of years
sadly it is still cited as truth
you would think that a guy who rose from
the dead and ascended into heaven for
all eyes to see and perform the wealth
of miracles acclaimed to him
would have made it into the historical
record
it didn't because once the evidence is
weighed there are very high odds that
the figure known as jesus did not even
exist
we don't want to be unkind but we want
to be factual
we don't want to cause hurt feelings
but we want to be academically correct
in what we understand and know to be
true
christianity just is not based on truth
we find that christianity was in fact
nothing more than a roman story
developed politically
the reality is jesus was the solar deity
of the gnostic christian sect
and like all other pagan gods he was a
mythical figure
it was the political establishment that
sought to historize the jesus figure for
social control
in 325 a.d in rome emperor constantine
convened the council of nicea
it was during this meeting that the
politically motivated christian
doctrines were established
and thus began a long history of
religious bloodshed and spiritual fraud
and for over the next 1 000 years the
vatican maintained a political
stranglehold on all of europe
leading to such joyous periods as the
dark ages
along with enlightening events such as
the crusades and the inquisition
christianity along with all other
related theologies
is an historical fraud
these religions now serve to detach the
species from the natural world and
likewise each other
they support blind submission to
authority
they reduce human responsibility to the
effect that god controls everything and
in turn awful crimes can be justified in
the name of a divine pursuit
and most critically
it empowers the political establishment
who have been using the myth to
manipulate and control societies
the religious myth is one of the most
powerful devices ever created and it
serves as the psychological soil upon
which other myths can flourish
[Music]
a myth
is an idea that while widely believed is
false
in a deeper
sense in the religious sense
a myth serves as an orienting and
mobilizing story for a people
the focus is not on the story's relation
to reality but on its function
a story cannot function
unless it is believed to be true in the
community or the nation
it is not a matter of debate
if some people have the bad taste
to raise the question of the truth of
the sacred story the keepers of the
faith do not enter into debate with them
they ignore them or denounce them as
blasphemers it is wrong blasphemous and
sinful for you to suggest imply or help
other people come to the conclusion that
the u.s government killed three thousand
of its own citizens
so
[Music]
as if a demolition team set off when you
see the old demolitions of these old
buildings it looks like one of those
scenes of an old building being
purposely dynamited and blown up anybody
who's ever watched a building being
demolished on purpose knows that if
you're going to do this you have to get
at the under infrastructure of a
building and bring it down the way the
structure is collapsing this was the
result of something that was planned
it's not accidental
that the first tower just happened to
collapse and then the second hour just
happened to collapse in exactly the same
way how they accomplished this we don't
know
the building collapsed to dust
you don't find a desk
you don't find a chair
you don't find a telephone a computer
the biggest piece of a telephone i found
was half of the keypad and it was about
this big
what happened to the concrete was
pulverized from river to river there was
dust powder two three inches thick the
concrete was just uh
pulverized in addition to those pictures
we've all seen too much on television
before when a building was deliberately
destroyed by well-placed dynamite to
knock it down
i heard a second explosion it wasn't a
heavy-duty explosion then also secondary
explosions and then the subsequent
collapses closure blue and it knocked
everybody over to me it sounded like an
explosion it sounded like gunfire
and then all of a sudden three big
explosions we heard a big explosion
coming down and then the entire top of
the building just blew up we saw some
kind of explosion by the force of the
explosions
back into the eighth floor when we get
to the lobby this is
though a bomb biggest exploded there a
huge explosion now raining debris it's
been a huge explosion huge explosion
that we all heard and felt we just
witnessed some kind of follow-up
explosion we heard a very loud
he thinks that there were actually
devices that were planted in the
building planted in the building
[Music]
i don't think anybody could have
predicted that they would try to use an
airplane as a missile a hijacked
airplane as a missile nobody in our
government at least and i don't think
the prior government that could envision
flying airplanes in the buildings no
specific threat involving really
domestic operation or involving
what happened obviously the city's
airliner and so there
were
no warning signs that i'm aware of usa
today reports that in the two years
before the attacks on september the 11th
norad conducted exercises using hijacked
airliners as weapons
and one target was the world trade
center
[Music]
in confidential documents from the
philippines obtained by cnn the plan was
clear
he will board any american commercial
aircraft control its cockpit and dive it
at the cia headquarters
other buildings targeted the pentagon
and the world trade center the federal
aviation administration received 52
warnings about al qaeda in the six
months before 9 11 and did not
apparently heed them pentagon reportedly
does not want the public to hear next
week's senate testimony about the former
secret intelligence unit known as able
danger and it identified muhammad atta
and three other 911 terrorists members
of an al qaeda cell in brooklyn new york
more than a year before the attacks we
found two of the three cells which
conducted the 9 11 attacks lieutenant
colonel tony schaefer who was the first
member of able danger to go public has
now been told in writing by the defense
intelligence agency that he can't speak
to members of congress or their staff
without prior approval this is an
attempt to prevent the american people
from knowing the facts about how we
could have prevented 911 and people are
covering it up today
security and counterterrorism was
blinking red
in the words of george tenet that the
warnings of an imminent attack were so
severe
that something dramatic should have been
done it was unparalleled
uh instead our president went on a
month-long vacation
[Music]
the head of pakistani intelligence at
the isi mahmoud ahmed requested omar
sheikh to wire a hundred thousand
dollars to muhammad atta who was the
lead hijacker did hijacker muhammad atta
received wire transfers via pakistan the
man sending the money to otta is
believed to be ahmed umar saeed sheikh
omar sheikh admitted he was supported by
the pakistan government's intelligence
service the isi
[Music]
as hard as this is to believe that two
of the alleged terrorists involved in
what happened on tuesday may have
attended schools run by the u.s military
evidence was also apparently planted
the passport of one of the hijackers on
flight 11 was allegedly found in the
rebel the hijacker's passport was found
blocks from the world trade center crash
site if you can believe that the 9 11
hijackers are alive and well that's
according to the chief of japan's
democratic party who says
9 11 is a hoax several of these 19 men
are still alive
[Music]
[Music]
of course we're after saddam hussein i
mean bin laden he's in the early 1980s
bin laden worked with operatives from
u.s intelligence the pakistani military
and arab states
january 2001
the bush administration
orders the fbi and intelligence agencies
to back off investigations involving the
bin laden family including two of osama
bin laden's relatives who were living
guess where in falls church virginia
right next to cia headquarters when he
was already america's most wanted
criminal
he reportedly spent two weeks in the
american hospital in dubai was treated
by an american doctor and visited by the
local cia agent we have not seen one
piece of evidence that links osama bin
laden directly to the planning stages of
september 11th this failure to provide
proof was later said to be unnecessary
because bin laden in a video allegedly
found in afghanistan admitted
responsibility for the attacks
[Music]
in
1976
osama's older brother salim bin laden
hired a man in texas by the name of jim
bath to handle all the investments in
the united states for the bin laden
family jim bath also happens to be a
personal almost lifelong friend and
former air national guard pilot with
george w bush
the connections between the bushes and
the bin ladens
become much more clear when george
herbert walker bush made trips to saudi
arabia in 1998 and 2000 to meet with
the bin laden family on behalf of a
company called the carlisle group
[Music]
how could anyone fly a 60 ton 125 foot
wide 44 foot tall plane through this
obstacle course the aircraft before
striking the pentagon reportedly
executed a 270 degree
downroot spiral and yet hani honuer was
known as a terrible pilot who could not
safely fly even a small plane
no seats no luggage no bodies
nothing but bricks and limestone the
official explanation is that the intense
heat from the jet fuel vaporized the
entire plane flight 77 had two
rolls-royce engines made of steel and
titanium alloy and weighs 6 tons each it
is scientifically impossible but 12 tons
of steel and titanium was vaporized by
jet fuel we're also told that the bodies
were able to be identified
either by their fingerprints or by the
dna
so what kind of fire can vaporize
aluminum and tempered steel
and yet leave leave human bodies intact
from my close-up inspection there's no
evidence of a plane having crashed
anywhere near the pentagon and as i said
the only pieces left
that you can see are are small enough
that you could pick up in your hand
shortly after the strike government
agents picked up debris and carried it
off
the entire lawn was covered with dirt
and gravel so that any remaining
forensic evidence was literally covered
up the videos from security cameras
which would show what really hit the
pentagon were immediately confiscated by
agents of the fbi and the department of
justice has to this day refused to
release them
if these videos would prove that the
pentagon was really hit by a 757 most of
us would assume the government would
release them
[Music]
it looks like there's nothing there
except for a hole in the ground
basically that's right the only thing
you could see from where we were
was a big gouge in the earth and some
broken trees we could see some people
working walking around in the area
but from where we could see there wasn't
much left any large pieces of debris at
all no there was nothing nothing that
you could distinguish that a plane had
crashed there
[Music]
[Music]
the fbi and the state police here have
confirmed that they have cordoned off a
second area about six to eight miles
away from the crater here this is
apparently another debris site
why would debris be located six miles
away could it have blown that far away
seems highly unlikely
[Music]
pancake theory
according to which the fires while not
melting the steel heated it up
sufficiently to cause the floors
weakened by the airplane strikes to
break loose from the steel columns and
this started a chain reaction so you
would expect then from that theory which
is the official theory to see a whole
stack of floors piled up on top of each
other and then a spindle of core column
standing too the core of each of the
twin towers consisted of 47 massive
steel columns if the floors had broken
loose from them these columns would have
still been sticking up into the air a
thousand feet
the plane did not cut all those core
columns we designed the buildings to
take the impact
of the boeing 707
hitting the building at any location the
building probably could sustain
multiple impacts of jetliners that the
plane flew straight into the building
right so you're saying that the building
was actually designed to cope with a
hole like that and still survive yeah it
was it was if you had dropped say a
billiard ball
from the top of the world trade center
110 floors up there it would have taken
8 to 10 seconds to hit the ground
encountering no resistance whatsoever
the twin towers came down in nearly free
fall speed 200 000 tons of steel
shatters and explodes outwards over 500
feet this means that floors shattered at
an average rate of about 10 floors per
second there is no scenario for a
pancake effect of buildings falling that
allows them to fall at the rate of free
fall now what can do that what can move
mass out of the way
explosives
47 huge steel columns going up the core
they're interconnected
how do you get
them to fail simultaneously so the cord
is pure it looks like those core columns
were cut
the way we do this is by cutting the
beam at an angle
i started looking at the molten metal
all three buildings both towers in the
rubble in the basement areas and
building seven there's these pools of
molten metal
get down below and you'd see
molten steel
molten steel running down the channel
like you're in a foundry
the molten steel was found three four
and five weeks later when the rubble was
being removed he said that molten steel
was also found underneath world trade
center seven
so i'm looking through the official
reports what do they say about the
molten metal
they say nothing
wait a minute
this is important evidence so where'd
that come from
thermite is so hot it'll just cut
through steel through structural steel
for example like a knife through butter
the products are molten iron and
aluminum oxide which goes off primarily
as a dust
you know those enormous dust clouds you
can imagine when you assemble these
chemicals on a large scale
so professor niels harrett you examined
the rubble that came from the world
trade center what did you find in it
well in there we find remains of what we
characterize as a thermitic material
and this is a very energetic material
which can be used either for melting
iron
or it can be designed as an explosive
the evidence for controlled demolition
is overwhelming i told you that the
thermite reaction produced molten iron
molten iron was in pools of molten iron
under in the rubble and and the point is
that the thermite kept on reacting this
was a beach's brew of thermite chemistry
molten metal pools under both towers
after they collapsed and building seven
now building seven wasn't even hit by a
jet
part of the problem is that most people
simply don't know much about building
seven due to the extraordinary secrecy
surrounding this collapse this was a
47-story skyscraper this building fell
at 5 25 it was not hit by a plane
this building had fires on only two or
three floors and it was brought down by
what we know
was a controlled demolition demolitions
they look just like that kink in the
middle and then that building just comes
straight down almost at free fall speed
[Music]
our office was on the b1 level as i was
talking to a supervisor at a46 and all
of a sudden we hear boom
an explosion so hard that pushes upwards
and it came from the basement between
the b2 level and the b3 level
and when i went to verbalize we hear
boom
the impact of the plane on the top
it would appear jim as if there's more
smoke coming from the ground i was down
in the basement came down all of a
sudden the elevator blew up and as we
were coming out we passed the lobby
there was no lobby so i believe the bomb
hit the lobby first and a couple of
seconds in the first plane hit as i'm
walking by the main freight car of the
building in the corridor
that's that's when i got blown
i mean the impact of the explosion threw
me to the floor and that's when
everything started happening all of a
sudden a big impact happened again
and all the ceiling tire was falling
down the light fixtures were falling you
know you got to go clear across the hole
from one to one to two world trade
center
and then all of a sudden it happened all
over again something else hit us to the
floor right in the basement you felt it
walls were caving in everything that was
going on
i mean i know people that got killed in
the basement i know people that got
broken legs in here in the basement
people got reconstructed for surgery
because the walls hit them in the face
[Music]
according to standard operating
procedure if an faa flight controller
notices anything that suggests a
possible hijacking controller is to
contact a superior if the problem cannot
be fixed within about a minute the
superiors to ask norad the north
american aerospace command to send up or
scramble jet fighters to find out what
is going on norad then issues the
scramble order to the nearest air force
base with fighters on alert although
interceptions usually occur within 10 or
so minutes in this case 80 or so minutes
had elapsed before fighters were even
airborne it's a mind-bending anomaly not
a single u.s air force interceptor turns
a wheel until it's too late there are no
jets at all what if they were so
confused
and had been so deliberately confused
that they couldn't respond the reason
that they didn't know where to go
was because a number of conflicting and
overlapping uh war game exercises were
taking place it involved the insertion
of false radar blips onto radar screens
in the northeast air defense sector
team u we have a problem here we have a
hijacked aircraft headed towards new
york we need someone to scramble
there's something up there to help us
out
is this real world or exercise is this
real world or exercise there was another
exercise vigilant warrior which was in
fact according to a norad source a live
fly hijack drill being conducted at the
same time with only eight available
fighter aircraft and they have to be
dispatched in pairs they were dealing
with as many as 22 possible hijacks on
the day of 9 11 and they couldn't
separate the war game exercises from the
actual hijacks
[Music]
page 172
the u.s government has not been able to
determine the origin of the money used
for the 9 11 attacks ultimately the
question is of little practical
significance the american authorities
have not managed to trace the source of
the funding and then the most amazingly
disingenuous statement ultimately is
that of little consequence it is a
massive consequence doesn't it matter
who paid for 911 the collapse of
building seven has been recognized as
especially difficult to explain
the 911 commission report implicitly
admitted that it could not explain the
collapse of this building
by not even mentioning it
why are you and the vice president
insisting on appearing together before
the 9 11 commission because the nine
commission 9 11 commission wants to ask
us questions that's why we're meeting
and i look forward to meeting with them
and answering their questions
why you're appearing together rather
than separately which was their request
because it's a good chance for both of
us to answer questions that the 911
commission is
looking forward to asking us and i'm
looking forward to answering them
let's see do you think they should be
able to stand up and and speak their own
words they should go under oath they
should be in public
[Music]
don't you think that the families
deserve to have a transcript or to be
able to see which you asked me that
question yesterday
i got the same answer yeah
the final report was a unanimous report
that means that if there was a single
commissioner who had any objection about
anything that fact would be dropped from
the report we have found out that he not
only served on the transition team of
the bush administration
that he was a person who wrote a draft
memo for the setup of the bush
administration's national security
council that he was an individual who
wrote the preemptive war strategy that
was eventually used for the war in iraq
that he is a close friend of condoleezza
rice's
we want him to resign there is literally
nothing in the 911 report that the bush
administration did not approve of
we can understand therefore why the
commission under zelikao's leadership
would have ignored all the evidence that
would point to the truth that 9 11 was a
false flag operation intended to
authorize the doctrines and funds needed
for a new level of imperial mobilization
[Music]
armed with knives armed with chemical
biological nuclear weapons fanatics
terrorist number 11 september 11th
killers timber elevators terrorists of
al-qaeda nuclear weapons terrorists 9 11
terror air terror evil december 11
september 11 the terrorist war and
danger september 11 terrorism global
terrorism terrorism terrorists
terrorists terrorists terrorists
terrorists the terror terrorists
terrorist terrorism september 11 global
terrorism terrorist terror terrorism
september 11 world terrorism terrorist
terrorism september 11 global terrorist
remember the 11th terror
terror territory weapons of mass
destruction september the 11th september
the 11th terrorist the evil terrorists
terrorists terrorists know terrorism
the words are hypnotically repeated
terrorism terrorist terrorist threat and
of course
believed to be linked to al-qaeda
but it's the so-called war on terrorism
that's in our faces practically 24 7 as
the inescapable focus of our existence
one day our grandchildren will look back
on this time and ask how was the war on
terror one the entire u.s ruling class
ruling elite comes to see terrorism as
the preferred means indeed the only
means
to provide social cohesion to provide an
enemy image for the society to keep it
together according to neocon theory from
carl schmidt you have to have an enemy
image in order to have a society a very
dangerous thing because now it means
that the entire social order the
political parties intellectual life
politics in general all based on a
monstrous myth monstrous myth
[Music]
look the cia has done in this country
what they've done to us it's
unbelievable look at the terrorist acts
that have occurred the cia behind most
if not all of them we had the marine
barracks better embassy in kenya
we had van am 103
we had the uss cole
we had oklahoma city we had the world
trade center in 1993.
that helped the terrorists blow up the
world trade center the first time
they built the bomb they they've got the
driver's license
the informant yet conformity salaam a 43
year old former egyptian army officer he
was given the assignment to put the bomb
together and he went to the supervisor
fbi supervisor and said we're going to
put dummy bombing here right and the fbi
supervisor said no we're going to put a
real bomb
fbi agents might have been able to
prevent last february's deadly explosion
at new york's world trade center they
discussed secretly substituting harmless
powder for the explosives but they
didn't according to the fbi's own
informant imad salem
unbeknownst to the fbi at the time salem
recorded many of his conversations with
his handlers
unfortunately for them
there were only six people killed not
enough to pass the legislation so what
happened is two years later april 19
1995
down comes oklahoma city uh murrah
building 168 people killed one year
later the anti-terrorism legislation
that takes away any of our
constitutional rights in civil areas is
passed
[Applause]
because at harpers nine this morning we
were actually running an exercise for
over a company of a thousand people in
london based on simultaneous bombs going
off precisely at the railway stations
that happened this morning so i still
have the hairs on the back of my legs
turning up right now did you get this
quite straight you were running uh an
exercise to see where how you would cope
with this and it happened while you were
running the exercise precisely
supposed to believe is some kind of
coincidence there was also an
anti-terrorist drill going on on 7-7 and
again just like 911 they were talking
about attacks on the same targets the
same kind of tube stations and exactly
the same time as the actual attack
happened providing some kind of cover
for what must be operations orchestrated
in some way by the state
[Applause]
i am absolutely appalled but how much
people in this country do not think
we are given to understand that
that a guy out there up in the mountains
financed the most elaborate attack on
this country do you think some people in
a cave do you think some people in a
cave were able to have norad stand down
do you think that people in a cave were
able to have all of this happen and when
i think about how many americans were
killed
in new york city and believing as i do
that this thing was a set up job this is
a textbook operation that nazis used and
they've used it over and over again
america has been suckered in one more
time
i don't have to tell you things are bad
everybody knows things are bad the
dollar buys and nickels worth banks are
going bust shopkeepers keep a gun under
the counter
punks are running wild in the street
there's nobody anywhere seems to know
what to do and there's no end to it
we know the air is unfit to breathe and
our food is unfit to eat
we sit watching our tvs while some local
newscaster tells us that today we had 15
homicides and 63 violent crimes as if
that's the way it's supposed to be we
know things are bad worse than bad
they're crazy it's like everything
everywhere is going crazy so we don't go
out anymore we sit in the house and
slowly the world we're living in is
getting smaller and all we say is please
at least leave us alone in our living
rooms let me have my toaster and my tv
and my steel belted radials and i won't
say anything just leave us alone well
i'm not gonna leave you alone
i want you to get mad
i don't want you to protest i don't want
you to ride i don't want you to write to
your congressman because i wouldn't know
what to tell you to write i don't know
what to do about the depression and the
inflation and the russians and the crime
in the street all i know is that first
you've got to get mad you've got to say
i'm a human being god damn it my life
has value
[Music]
[Applause]
broken windows
when hostilities commenced in europe in
1939
it was realized that the american people
had no intention of entering the war
but they believed that this country
could be enticed into the war
in very much the same way that it was
enticed into the last one
they planned first
to prepare the united states for foreign
war
under the guise of american defense
second to involve us in the war
step by step
without our realization
third
to create a series of incidents
which would force us into the actual
conflict
these plans were of course
to be covered and assisted by the full
power of their propaganda
our theaters soon became filled with
plays portraying the glory of war
newsreels lost all semblance of
objectivity
and they have used the war
to justify the restriction of
congressional power
and the assumption of dictatorial
procedures on the part of the president
and his appointees
a fear campaign was inaugurated
we cannot allow
the natural passions and prejudices
of other peoples
to lead our country to destruction
[Music]
1775
the american revolutionary war began as
the american colonies sought to detach
from england and its oppressive monarchy
though many reasons are cited for the
revolution one in particular sticks out
as a prime cause
that king george iii of england outlawed
the interest-free independent currency
the colonies were producing themselves
in turn forcing them to borrow money
from the central bank of england
immediately creating economic hardship
and despair in the words of peter cooper
former vice president of the new york
board of currency after franklin had
explained to the british government as
the real cause of prosperity they
immediately passed laws forbidding the
payment of taxes in that money this
produced such great inconvenience and
misery to the people that it was the
principal cause of the revolution
in 1783 america won its independence
from england however its battle against
the central bank concept and the corrupt
power hungry mentality associated with
it had just begun
so what is a central bank
a central bank is an institution that
issues and regulates the currency of an
entire nation
based on historical precedent the
typical powers inherent in central
banking practice include the control of
interest rates and the expansion and
contraction of the money supply itself
now the central bank does not simply
issue money to the government it loans
it to them with interest
then through the mechanisms of
increasing and decreasing the supply of
money the central bank essentially
regulates the value of the currency
issued
it is critical to understand that the
entire structure of this system could
only produce one thing in the long run
debt
it doesn't take a lot of ingenuity to
figure this scam out for every single
dollar produced by both the central bank
and its regulated commercial banks is
loaned at interest
that means every dollar produced is
actually the dollar plus a certain
percentage of debt based on that dollar
and since the banking system has the
monopoly of the production of the
currency
and they loan each dollar out with an
immediate debt attached to it
where does the money to pay for the debt
come from
it can only come from the banks again
which means the banking system has to
perpetually increase its money supply to
temporarily cover the outstanding debt
created which in turn since that new
money is loaned out at interest as well
creates even more debt
the end result of this system is
essentially slavery for it is
technically impossible for the
government and thus the public to ever
come out of the self-generating debt
by the early 20th century the us had
already implemented and removed a few
central banking systems which were
maneuvered into place by ruthless
banking interests at this time the
dominant families in the banking and
business world were the rockefellers the
morgans the warburgs the rothschilds
and in the early 1900s they sought to
push once again legislation to create
another central bank
however they knew the government and
public were very weary of such an
institution so they needed to create an
incident to affect public opinion
so jp morgan publicly considered a
financial luminary at the time
exploited his mass influence by
reportedly creating rumors that
prominent banks in new york were
insolvent or bankrupt morgan knew this
would trigger mass hysteria and a
systemic crisis
and it did
the public in fear of losing their
deposits immediately began mass
withdrawals consequently the banks were
forced to call in their loans causing
the recipients to sell their property
and thus a spiral of bankruptcy's
repossessions and turmoil emerged
putting the pieces together years later
congressman charles lindbergh wrote the
king bankers put in motion in 1907 a
great scheme they had gambled and
speculated on wall street until so many
watered stocks and bonds had been
manufactured the king bankers knew the
condition and informed the favorite of
their friends what was to come there was
to be a panic in the fall of 1907 and it
would be advertised as the result of our
bad banking and currency laws
the panic of 1907 led to a congressional
investigation headed by senator nelson
aldrich who had intimate ties to the
financial powers and later became part
of the rockefeller family through
marriage
the commission led by aldrich
recommended a central bank should be
implemented so a panic like 1907 could
never happen again
this was the spark that the bankers
needed to initiate their plan
and in 1910 a secret meeting was held at
a jp morgan estate on jekyll island off
the coast of georgia it was there that
the central banking bill called the
federal reserve act was written this
legislation was written by bankers not
lawmakers this meeting was so secretive
so concealed from government and public
knowledge that most of the figures who
attended disguised their names when
enroute to the island and after this
bill was constructed it was then handed
over to their political front man
senator nelson aldrick to push through
congress and in 1913 with heavy
political sponsorship by the bankers
woodrow wilson became president
having already agreed to sign the
federal reserve act in exchange for
campaign support
and a few days before christmas when
much of congress was at home with their
families the federal reserve act was
voted in and wilson in turn made it law
the night before its passage congressman
charles lindbergh pleaded
this act establishes the most gigantic
trust on earth when the president signs
this act the invisible government by the
money power will be legalized
now the public was told that the federal
reserve system was an economic
stabilizer and inflation and economic
crises were a thing of the past
well as history has shown nothing was
further from the truth the fact is the
bankers now had a streamlined machine
for economic manipulation
[Music]
for example from 1914 to 1919 the fed
substantially increased the money supply
resulting in extensive loans to small
banks and the public
then in 1920 the fed deliberately
contracted credit in an extreme way thus
resulting in banks having to call in
large numbers of loans and just like
1907 bank runs bankruptcy and systemic
collapse occurred
numerous competitive banks outside of
the federal reserve system collapsed
further consolidating the monopoly of
the money trust cartel
privy to this scheme congressman
lindbergh pronounced
under the federal reserve act panics are
scientifically created the present panic
is the first scientifically created one
worked out as we figure a mathematical
equation
however the panic of 1920 was just a
warm-up
from 1921 to 1929 the fed again
increased the money supply resulting
once again in extensive loans to the
public and banks
there was also a fairly new type of loan
in the stock market the broker call loan
very simply this loan allowed an
investor to put down only a fraction of
the stock's value with the rest being
loaned from the broker
this method was very popular in the
roaring 1920s as everyone seemed to be
making money in the market
however there was a catch to this loan
it could be called in at any time and
had to be paid within 24 hours and the
typical result was the selling of the
stock purchased with that loan
so a few months before october and 1929
jd rockefeller bernard baruch and many
other insiders quietly exited the market
knowing the bubble created was about to
burst
then on october 24th 1929 the financiers
who furnished the call loans started
calling them in in mass
this sparked an instantaneous massive
sell-off in the already inflated market
has sell orders and margin calls were
systemically triggered that then led to
mass bank runs eventually collapsing
thousands of banks enabling the large
banks to buy up the now failed banks at
a discount
but it didn't stop there rather than
expanding the money supply in order to
recover from this economic collapse the
fed actually contracted it fueling one
of the largest depressions in american
history
outraged congressman louis mcfadden then
chairman of the house banking committee
filed petition for impeachment against
the federal reserve board
stating
mr chairman we have in this country one
of the most corrupt institutions the
world has ever known i refer to the
federal reserve board and the federal
reserve banks
this evil institution has impoverished
and ruined the people of the united
states and has practically bankrupted
our government it has done this through
the defects of the law under which it
operates through the mal administration
of that law by the federal reserve board
and through the corrupt practices of the
moneyed vultures who control it
now having reduced the society of the
squalor it was then decided that the
gold standard should be removed in order
to do this they needed to acquire the
remaining gold in the system so under
the pretense of helping to end the
depression came the 1933 gold seizure
under the threat of imprisonment for 10
years everyone in america was required
to turn in all gold bullion to the
treasury essentially robbing the public
of what little wealth they had left and
at the end of 1933 the gold standard was
abolished if you look at a dollar bill
before 1933 it says it is redeemable in
gold if you look at the dollar bill
today it says it is legal tender which
means it is backed by absolutely nothing
the only thing that gives our money
value is the public faith and how much
of it is in circulation
therefore the power to regulate the
money supply is also the power to
regulate its value which is also the
power to manipulate and control entire
economies
it is important to clearly understand
the federal reserve is a private
corporation it is about as federal as
federal express
it makes its own policies and is under
little regulation by the us government
it is a private bank that loans all the
currency at interest to the government
completely consistent with the central
banking model that the country sought to
escape from when it declared
independence in the american
revolutionary war
now going back to 1913 the federal
reserve act was not the only bill pushed
through congress for the vested
financial interests they also pushed its
partner the federal income tax
first of all the federal income tax is
completely unconstitutional as it is a
direct unapportioned tax and the
required number of states needed in
order to ratify the amendment to allow
the income tax was never legally met and
this has even been cited in modern court
cases
second at the present day roughly 25 of
the average worker's income is taken
from them via this tax that means you
work three months out of the year to
fulfill this tax obligation and where
does that money go
according to the grace commission report
of the 1980s 100 percent of what is
collected is absorbed solely by interest
on the federal debt and by federal
government contributions to transfer
payments
in other words all individual income tax
revenues are gone before one nickel is
spent on the services which taxpayers
expect from their government
today the money americans make working
three months out of the year goes almost
entirely to the interest fees charged
for the debt-based fiat currency
the fact is the federal income tax
exists to feed the federal reserve
federal government money machine making
sure the interest payments are always
there
and third even with the government claim
as to the legality of the income tax
there is still evidently no statute no
law in existence that requires you to
pay this tax
i really expected that of course there's
a law that you can point to
in the law book the code that requires
you to file a tax return of course there
is
i was at that point where i couldn't
find the statute that clearly made a
person liable
at least not me and most people i know
and i had no no choice in my mind except
to to resign based on the research that
i did throughout the year 2000 and that
i'm still doing i have not found that
law i've asked congress we've asked a
lot of people in the irs irs
commissioners helpers
they can't answer because if they answer
the american people are going to know
that this whole thing is a fraud
i haven't filed an income federal income
tax return since i left i have not filed
a tax return since 1999
now the control of the economy and the
manipulation of society for the vested
financial powers is only a part of the
game being played
another level is the business of war
since the inception of the federal
reserve in 1913 a number of large and
small wars have commenced the three most
pronounced might be world war one world
war ii and vietnam
world war one in 1914 european wars
broke out centered around england and
germany the american public wanted
nothing to do with the war in turn
president woodrow wilson publicly
declared neutrality however under the
surface evidence now shows that the
financial powers behind the
administration were looking for any
excuse it could to enter it it is
important to understand that one of the
most lucrative things that can happen
for the bankers is war for it forces the
country to borrow even more money at
interest not to mention the profits
generated through the financing of
military production
in the words of two-time congressional
medal of honor winner smedly d butler
war is a racket it always has been it is
possibly the oldest easily the most
profitable surely the most vicious it is
the only one international in scope and
it is the only one in which the profits
are reckoned in dollars and the losses
in lives
woodrow wilson's top advisor and mentor
was colonel edward house
a man found to have intimate connections
with the financial interests of the time
in a conversation with colonel house
wilson's advisor and sir edward gray the
foreign secretary of england regarding
america and the war gray inquired
what will america do if germans sink an
ocean liner with american passengers on
board house responded i believe that a
flame of indignation would sweep the
united states and that by itself would
be sufficient to carry us into war
so on may 7 1915 a ship called the
lusitania was sent where german military
vessels were known to be
and as likely expected german u-boats
torpedoed the ship exploding stored
munitions killing 1200 people
to further understand the obvious
anticipation of this setup the german
embassy actually put advertisements in
the new york times telling people that
if they boarded the lusitania they did
so at their own risk as such a ship
sailing from america to england through
the war zone would be liable to
destruction
in turn and as anticipated the sinking
of the lusitania caused a wave of anger
among the american population and
america entered the war a short time
after
major general smedley d butler
summarizes the monetary reality of world
war one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
world war ii
on december 7th 1941 japan attacked the
american fleet at pearl harbor
triggering u.s entry into that war
president franklin d roosevelt declared
the attack was a day that will live in
infamy a day of infamy indeed but not
because of the alleged surprise attack
on pearl harbor after 60 years of
surfacing information it is now clear
that not only was the attack known well
in advance it was outright wanted and
provoked
in a journal entry by roosevelt's
secretary of war henry stimson dated
november 25th 1941 he documented a
conversation he had with roosevelt
the question was how we should maneuver
them into firing the first shot
and in congressional testimony later he
added
it was desirable to make sure the
japanese be the ones to do this so that
there should remain no doubt as to who
were the aggressors in the months
leading up to the attack on pearl harbor
roosevelt had done almost everything in
his power to anger the japanese showing
a posture of aggression he halted all of
japan's imports of american petroleum he
froze all japanese assets in the united
states he made public loans to
nationalist china and supplied military
aid to the british both enemies of japan
and the war which by the way was in
complete violation of international war
rules and with numerous japanese codes
broken in advance revealing the plan to
attack on december 7 1941 japan was
allowed to attack pearl harbor killing 2
400 soldiers
before pearl harbor 83 percent of the
american public wanted nothing to do
with the war
after pearl harbor one million men
volunteered
it is important to note nazi germany's
war effort was largely supported by two
organizations one of which was called ig
farbin ig farben produced 84 of
germany's explosives one of the unspoken
partners of ig farben was jd
rockefeller's standard oil company in
america in fact the german air force
could not operate without a special
additive patented by rockefeller's
standard oil the drastic bombing of
london by nazi germany for example was
made possible by a 20 million dollar
sale of fuel to ig farben by the
rockefeller's standard oil company this
is just one small point on the topic of
how american business funded both sides
of world war ii
one other treasonous organization worth
mentioning is the union banking
corporation of new york city not only
did they finance numerous aspects of
hitler's rise to power along with actual
materials during the war it was also a
nazi money laundering bank which was
eventually exposed for having millions
of dollars of nazi money in its faults
the union banking corporation of new
york was eventually seized for
violations of the trading with the enemy
act guess who the director and vice
president of the union bank was
prescott bush
the father and grandfather of former u.s
presidents george w bush and george h.w
bush
vietnam the united states official
escalation and entry into the vietnam
war came after an alleged incident
involving two u.s destroyers being
attacked by north vietnamese pt boats in
the gulf of tonkin this is known as the
gulf of tonkin incident this situation
was the catalystic pretext for massive
troop deployment and full-fledged
warfare
one problem however the attack on the
u.s destroyers by vietnamese pt boats
never happened
former secretary of defense robert
mcnamara stated years later that the
gulf of tonkin incident was a mistake
while classified documents released
years later show that it was a farce
manipulated for the purposes of war
and once in the war it was business as
usual
in october 1966 president lyndon johnson
lifted trade restrictions on the soviet
bloc knowing full well that the soviets
were providing upwards of 80 of north
vietnam's war supplies
consequently the rockefeller interests
financed factories in the soviet union
which the soviets used to manufacture
military equipment and send to north
vietnam
however the funding of both sides in
this conflict was only one side of the
coin in 1985 vietnam's rules of
engagement were declassified this
detailed what american troops were and
were not allowed to do in the war it
included such absurdities as north
vietnamese anti-aircraft missile systems
could not be bombed until they were
known to be operational no enemy could
be pursued once they crossed the border
of laos or cambodia and most revealing
of all the most critical strategic
targets were not allowed to be attacked
unless initiated via high military
officials
apart from these illogical limitations
north vietnam was informed of these
restrictions and therefore could base
entire strategies around the limitations
of the american forces
this is why the war went on for so long
and the bottom line is this the vietnam
war was never meant to be won just
sustained
this war for profit and resources
resulted in 58 000 american deaths and
three million dead vietnamese
so
where are we now
september 11th was the jump start for a
hegemonic agenda enabling the
possibility of constant global warfare
it was a staged war pretext no different
than the sinking of the lusitania the
provoking of pearl harbor and the gulf
of tonkin lie
in fact if 9 11 wasn't a planned war
pretext it would be an exception to the
rule it has been used to launch two
unprovoked illegal wars one against iraq
and the other against afghanistan
however 9 11 was a pretext for another
war as well
the war against you
the patriot act homeland security the
military tribunals act and other
legislations are all completely designed
to destroy your civil liberties and
protect those in power
currently in the united states
unannounced to most americans your home
can be searched without a warrant
without you being home
you can in turn be detained indefinitely
with no charges revealed to you
no access to a lawyer and legally
tortured
all under the suspicion that you might
be a terrorist
if you need a painted picture of what is
happening let's recognize how history
repeats itself
in february 1933 hitler staged the false
flag attack
burning down his own german parliament
building the reichstag blaming it on
communist terrorists
within the next few weeks he passed the
enabling act which completely eradicated
the german constitution destroying
people's liberties
he then led a series of pre-emptive wars
all justified as necessary to
maintaining homeland security
[Music]
[Applause]
our enemy is a radical network of
terrorists
and every government that supports them
[Applause]
it's time to wake up
the people in power go out of their way
to make sure you are perpetually misled
and manipulated
majorities perception of reality
especially in the political arena is not
their own
it is shrewdly imposed upon them without
them even knowing it
for example the public at large now
believes the invasions of iraq and the
middle east along with the resulting
instability are the consequences of
political and military mistakes
what the public fails to see of course
is that the destabilization of the
middle east is exactly what the western
interests want
this war is to be sustained so the
region can be divided up domination of
the oil maintained continual profits
reaped for defense contractors
and most obviously permanent military
bases established to be used as
launching pads against other oil-bearing
non-conforming countries such as iran
for further implication that the civil
war and destabilization is purely
intentional in 2005 two elite british
sas officers were arrested by iraqi
police after being caught driving around
in their car
shooting at civilians while dressed up
as arabs after being arrested and taken
to a jail in basra the british army
immediately demanded release of these
men
when the basra government refused
british tanks came in and physically
broke out the men from the basra prison
if you wish to destroy
an area how do you do it well in two
ways you can go in there and bomb it and
so forth but that is not very efficient
what you do is you try to get the people
in that area to kill each other and to
destroy their own territory
their own farms
and that's what's been done in that area
the way in which you destroy an opponent
is get him to destroy himself by
dividing his ranks against one another
then you feed both sides you have agents
feeding both sides inflaming both sides
and they kill each other off
and it's time that some of us woke up to
this reality
to understand
that people who try to maintain empires
and create empires
do it by manipulating the people they're
trying to conquer
you might want to ask yourself why the
entire culture is utterly saturated with
mass media entertainment from all sides
while the educational system in america
continues its stupefying downward slides
since the u.s government decided to take
over and subsidize the public school
system
what your government pays for it gets
when we understand that
then we look at government financed
institutions of education
and see the kind of students and the
kind of education that's being turned
out by these government finance schools
logic will tell you that if what is
being turned out in those schools was
not in accord with what the state and
the federal government wanted
then it would change it
the bottom line is that the government
is getting what they have ordered
they do not want your children to be
educated
they do not want you to think too much
that is why our country and our world
has become so proliferated with
entertainments
mass media
television shows amusement parks drugs
alcohol
and every kind of entertainment to keep
the human mind entertained
so that you don't get in the way of
important people by doing too much
thinking
you have better wake up and understand
that there are people who are guiding
your life and you don't even know it
we're in a lot of trouble
because you people and 62 million other
americans are listening to me right now
because less than three percent of you
people read books
because less than 15 percent of you read
newspapers because the only truth you
know is what you get over this tube
right now there is a whole an entire
generation that never knew anything that
didn't come out of this tube
this tube is the gospel
the ultimate revelation
this tube can make or break presidents
popes prime ministers this tube is the
most awesome goddamn force in the whole
godless world and woes us if it ever
falls in the hands of the wrong people
and when the largest company in the
world controls the most awesome goddamn
propaganda force in the whole godless
world who knows what [ __ ] will be better
for truth on this network
so you listen to me
listen to me television is not the truth
television is a goddamn amusement park
television is a circus a carnival a
traveling troupe of acrobats
storytellers dancers singers jugglers
sideshow freaks lion tamers and football
players we're in the boredom killing
business
but you people sit there day after day
night after night all ages colors queens
we're all you know you're beginning to
believe the illusions we're spinning
here you're beginning to think that the
tube is reality and that your own lives
are unreal you do whatever the tube
tells you you drift like a tube you
ain't like the tube you raise your
children like a tube you even think like
the tube this is mass madness you
maniacs in god's name you people are the
real thing we are the illusion
the last thing the power establishment
wants is a conscious informed public
capable of critical thinking
this is why a continually fraudulent
zeitgeist is output via religion the
mass media and the educational system it
is in their interest to keep you in a
distracted naive bubble
and they are doing a damn good job of it
[Music]
this is aaron russo a filmmaker and
former politician to his left is
nicholas rockefeller of the council on
foreign relations
after maintaining a close friendship
with nicholas aaron eventually ended the
relationship appalled by what he had
learned
i got a call one day from um an attorney
woman i knew
and she said would you like to meet one
of the rockefellers
i said sure i'd love to
and uh we became friends and um
he began to divulge a lot of things to
me
so he said to me one night he said that
uh there's gonna be an event there
and out of that event you're gonna see
we're gonna go into afghanistan so we
can run pipelines from the caspian sea
we're gonna go into iraq
to take the oil and establish a base in
the middle east and we're gonna go into
venezuela and then try and get and get
rid of chavez
and uh the first two they've
accomplished chavez they didn't
accomplish
and uh they said you're gonna see guys
going to caves looking for
looking for people that they're never
going to find
you know he's laughing about the fact
that you have this war
on terror there's no real enemy he's
talking about
how
by having this war on turret you can
never win it because this is the eternal
war and so you can always keep taking
people's liberties away
and i said how you can convince people
that this war is real he says but the
media the media can convince everybody
it's real i mean
you know it's just that you keep talking
about things you keep saying it over and
over and over again and eventually
people believe it
you know you created the federal reserve
in 1913 through lies you create 911
which is another lie
through 9 11 you then you're fighting a
war on terror and that was when you go
into iraq which was another lie
and now they're going to do iran
you know and so one thing leading to
another leading to another leading to
another now i would say that why what
are you doing this for what what's the
point of this thing you have all the
money in the world you ever want you
have all the power i said you know
you're hurting people it's not a good
thing and you would say what do you care
about the people for take care of
yourself and you take care of your
family
and then i said to what's the ulti what
are the ultimate goals here
to the ultimate goal the ultimate goal
is to get everybody in this world
chipped into the tree with the rfid chip
and have all money be on those chips and
everything on those chips
and if anybody wants to protest what we
do or violate what we want we just turn
off their chip
so how far will the sickness of power go
to what lengths will those in control go
in order to maintain and preserve their
positions
we have a florida family
who are really pioneers in a brave new
world they have volunteered to be the
first ever to have microchip
identification devices implanted into
their body after 9 11 i was really
concerned with the security of my family
i wouldn't mind having something planted
permanently in my arm that would
identify me
george orwell in his famed and possibly
prophetic work 1984 stated
power is not a means it is an end
the object of persecution is persecution
the object of torture is torture the
object of power is power
today symptoms of a surveillance society
continue to grow as irrational fears of
invisible enemies coupled with rising
economic instability spread across the
globe it is under this guise of security
that we can foreshadow a world where
everyone is tracked everyone is on
camera and everyone is subordinated
the most incredible aspect of all
such totalitarianism would likely not be
forced upon the people
rather the people will demand it
for the social manipulation of society
through the generation of fear and
division has completely inhibited the
culture
religion patriotism
race
wealth class and every other form of
arbitrary separatist identification and
thus conceit has served to create a
controlled population utterly malleable
in the hands of the few
divide and conquer is the motto and as
long as people continue to see
themselves as separate from everything
else they lend themselves to being
completely enslaved
however if the people ever realize the
truth of their relationship to nature
and the truth of their personal power to
effect change
the entire manufactured zeitgeist that's
preyed upon
would collapse like a house of cards
[Music]
the whole
system
that we live in
drills into us that we're powerless that
we're weak that our society is evil that
it's private and etc and so forth it's
all a big fat lie
we are powerful beautiful extraordinary
there is no reason why we cannot
understand
who we truly are
where we are going there is no reason
why the average individual cannot be
fully empowered we are incredibly
powerful beings
now i think i spent 30 years of my life
in the first 30 trying to become
something
i want to become good at things i want
to become good at tennis i want to
become good at school and great and
everything i kind of viewed in that
perspective i'm not okay the way i am
but if i got good at things
you realize that i had the game wrong
the game was to find out what i already
was find out what i already was
[Music]
now in our culture we've been trained
for individual differences to stand out
so you look at each person the immediate
kid is brighter dumber older younger
richer poorer and we make all these
dimensional distinctions put them in
categories and treat them that way
and we get so that we only see others as
separate from ourselves in the ways in
which they're separate
and one of the
dramatic characteristics of experience
is being with another person and
suddenly seeing the ways in which they
are like you not different from you
and experiencing the fact that which is
essence in you and which is essence in
me is indeed one
the understanding that there is no other
it is all one
and i wasn't born richard albert i was
just born as a human being and then i
learned this whole
business of who i am and whether i'm
good or bad or
achieving or not all that's learned
along the way
[Music]
the old appeals to
racial sexual religious chauvinism to
rabid
nationalist fervor
are beginning not to work
a new consciousness is developing which
sees the earth as a
single organism
and recognizes
that an organism at war with itself
is dueled
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
bill hicks used to finish his shows
with this
life's like a ride in an amusement park
when you go on it you think it's real
because that's how powerful our minds
are and the ride goes up and down and
round and round it has thrills and
chills and it's very brightly colored
and it's very loud and it's fun for a
while
some have been on the ride for a long
time and they begin to question is this
real or it's just a ride
and other people have remembered and
they come back to us and they say hey
don't worry don't be afraid ever
because this is just a ride
and we kill those people
shut him up i better not invested in
this ride shut him up
look at my furrows of worry look at my
big bank account my family this has to
be real
[Music]
it's just a ride
i will kill those good guys and try and
tell us that you ever notice that and
let the demons run amok
but it doesn't matter
because it's just a ride and we can
change against anyone
it's only a choice no effort no work no
job no savings or money just a choice
right now
between fear
and love
[Music]
you